actualmente mi esposo cumplirá ocho
meses de estar secuestrado decimos
nosotros porque en realidad no ha
cometido ningún delito más que defender
sus derechos ciudadanos y actualmente
hemos sabido que él ha perdido casi 50
libras se encuentra en una celda
completamente en penumbra acompañado por
otro preso político no tiene acceso a la
luz solar más que cada 10 a 15 días por
10 minutos sujetos interrogatorios
constantes y claramente al igual que el
ac se encuentra también el resto de las
personas presas políticas en cara ua
libertad que supone este nuevo juicio
contra más de 40 encarcelados y que
garantías judiciales tienen
nosotros como familiares creemos que
estos son juicios ilegales son muy los
juicios que están sustentados por leyes
que fueron creadas por el régimen para
detener cualquier tipo de movilización
ciudadana recordemos que dentro de las
personas que serán juzgadas próximamente
se encuentran siete de los precandidatos
a la presidencia
entre ellos mi esposo félix maradiaga y
en términos de defensa legal no no
existe ninguna garantía actualmente en
el país hay una clara violación al
debido proceso y con esto por ejemplo
cuando se anunció la reanudación de
estos juicios que habían sido detenidos
desde octubre del año pasado la fiscalía
les llamó criminales y delincuentes
violando el la presunción de inocencia
que cualquier persona que pasa por un
proceso legal debería de tener
y tienen algún tipo de información sobre
la situación en la que se encuentran el
resto de encarcelados hemos hablado ya
de su marido pero me imagino que ustedes
manejan información sobre todos los
encarcelados
así es actualmente en nicaragua existen
170 personas presas políticas de estas
170 alrededor de 120 que llevan ya casi
13 años de estar en prisión y hay un
grupo que fue secuestrado después de
mayo del año pasado estos son el
liderazgo de nicaragua hay alrededor de
42 personas que se encuentran en las
celdas conocidas como el chipote y estas
personas es donde está mi esposo también
están sufriendo otros tipos de torturas
por ejemplo conocemos el caso de rojas
rey es uno de los defensores y también
abogado de félix que han sufrido
psicosis está perdiendo la memoria
personas que están incomunicadas
completamente y personas que están
perdiendo más de 60 libras es por el
proceso
berta muchas gracias por atendernos en
france 24